Bảo cao của Iban Kánh tranh Quốc gia tại hội gịt tổng kết công tác quả lý hoạt động
mang hàng đa cấp năm 2020. Cả nước hiện có hình bày trong nghìn người tham gia
bán hàng đa cấp, bới xanh thu tần nền đặt hơn mùi sáo nghìn tì đồng.
Trong đó, thực phẩm bộ xung xú khỏe chim tới tả mấy chiến phần trăm tổng
xanh thu còn lại là Mỹ phẩm, quân hảo, thời trang, thiết bị đô ra giụv và các
sân phẩm khác. Tuy nhiên, thu nhập bình quân tự hoa hồng, tiến thưởng chỉ đặt
khoảng chiến trăm năm 2020, tương đường 12.000 tuy nhập bình quân đồng
mùi của cả nước trong năm 2020. Tình đến nay, trên cả nước có năm 1970,
đế phương bán hàng quy trị phối hợp trong công tác thành trà, kiểm tra, giám sát hỏa đồng
kinh dành đa cấp. Năm qua, các quan trức năng đá sự và thành chính bẩy zân gẹp
bị phạm với tổng số tiền một phẩy bố mê sáo tì đồng, đồng thời thu hội dễ chim nhận
một dân gịp. Tuy công tác quả lý được chiến khai đồng bộ tuy chung đến
để phương nhưng tình trạng lợi dụng mua hình bán hàng đa cấp để tổ chức hội thảo chá hình,
lôi kéo chai phép bánh dính biến phút tạm. Một công tương yêu cầu tăng cường
với hợp sữa lực lượng công an, cạnh sát với cơ quan của lý ngày công tương trong việc
phát hiện và sử lý vý phạm.